you mentioned the Daily Show gotta ask
how do you like that gig
I like it I think it's I think late
night's changing I don't know what
though yeah so that's the thing that's a
little uneasy it's been very fun you
know Trevor's departure was definitely
not a shock
him leaving was not a shock to me when
was more the shot and how yeah you know
like yeah that but because I don't even
think anybody knew no one knew yeah
naughty soul and he just said it on the
show and then we went to a commercial
break it's like what so have you asked
him why that about that thought process
that went behind that or is that a
mistake I think a lot of it was just
boiled down to I just didn't want
anybody to talk me out of it because
when you're doing something at
Monumental everybody's gonna have an
opinion and that's just him taking
control over his own life and decisions
so I respect it I
I enjoy it I've had a lot of fun on The
Daily Show the question becomes what is
late night
changing into because our job is to
parody the news but
if the way people get their news is
changing
then the vehicles and how we
parody have to match the evolution of
how news is consumed yeah
but how news is being consumed that's
the question that has to be explored and
looked at how do you parody Marjorie
Taylor green how do you parody what's
really happening because because what's
really happening has become you know and
Santos and back in the day uh when I was
getting started writing comedy in
college you know I was part of this
Lampoon organization that would do like
a Parry of Time Magazine a parody of
Newsweek and you can parody something
that's got a straight line you can
parody something that's very stiff and
form universally everybody understands
understands and then so a parody of it
is kind of delightful but we always knew
you can't parody The National Enquirer I
think Saturday Night Live struggles with
that I think everybody struggles with it
yeah I do think that there is a way to
fish in a different Pond from
the traditional people who we get the
opinions from yep yep so I think that's
part of the evolution you know when you
look at Tick Tock and Instagram what's
interesting and what and a lot of this
is from the shutdown
a lot of people who were former
consumers of information
now purport themselves to be
Distributors yeah of information and we
Regular Joe Blow people accept them
as aggregators as well
this guy Tim said it so let me see what
Tim has to say he's got a good camera
and that's a nice lens
I trust Tim now I got a good beanbag
chair behind him yeah I follow him on
YouTube now so there are more people
putting information out there as well
and I think to a degree you know as a
society
as a country at least
we've become okay with not caring who we
get our news from yeah or the accuracy
of it
and I think that the parody lies in that
yeah I think the parody lies not
necessarily in what the news of the day
is but the delivery method of it you
know and as we would you know people go
to bed like let's just be real about the
latings the ratings of linear television
as a whole yeah not even late night
everything's going down so if ratings
are going down
part of it is because people are laying
in bed looking at Tim in his bean bag
and his LED light because that's just as
good and entertaining for them yeah as
what's nice and Polished on a shiny
floor Studio I will tell you this uh I'm
an old timer and I came up in late night
at a time when late night shows there
weren't that many
but because of the way TV was structured
these shows made money hand over fist
and that's why
shows had an orchestra they had a big
band they had you know money uh that is
not the way it is anymore and so you
will see the effects the effects will be
maybe some of these late night shows uh
uh you know as hosts retire or leave
will be replaced with something else
maybe that time will go back to the
Affiliates everyone's speculating but
yeah who knows what's going to happen I
do have to say this because I know
you're a busy man I want to let you go
but
I do
sincerely feel
really good that you're out there all
right you're a you're a really good man
you're a very uh thoughtful and
increasingly talented and I'm glad
you're out there and you're thinking
about this because I think it makes me
feel better about the whole world of
Comedy I'm serious I'm being honest with
you it makes me uh I
always have been very impressed with you
and I'm just the more you do the more
just crazily impressed I am so
uh go forth continue uh doing
great work and I know that we're in good
hands like when I meet people much
younger than me who are
you know ethical and and wise and
creative I feel better I sleep better at
night so thank you seriously
thank you brother yeah appreciate you
for having me well I appreciate you now
please get out
[Laughter]
I wanted it to end with me throwing you
out get out I said get out